[Music]
hello everyone I'm first mate
James first mate again shocking joint
vote cabin-boy
Oscar Deus come on please let me be
we're here to talk about sea of thieves
so Oscar you went to rare a dish you had
a great day out it rare I did North
England how long did you play Steve
useful about 2 hours of gameplay all
told yeah so what you're seeing right
now is 4k gameplay that we well Oscar
captured on PC you might notice that
it's a little bit quiet yeah so we had
some issues with capture there was a
weird kind of sound effect that I
couldn't get rid of we asked her for a
clean copy of the audio and sadly the
party chat was hard-coded into it so it
would sound very strange if we were
happy if we were talking over this
gameplay and you could hear other people
talking so I've just kind of muted it
but I did scour some audio and audio
libraries to find some pirate
appropriate music so sorry about that
but you can you can see what the game
looks like it's very pretty it's very
pretty isn't it so Oscar
I've played like maybe an hour half of
CFDs as well and it's a game that when
you're playing it I really really
enjoyed it mm-hmm I was having a lot of
fun with my friends but the act of
actually explaining it to people I feel
like it's a game that doesn't really
translate when you try and explain the
premise yeah it's a really difficult
game to sort of sell in one it doesn't
have like one big hook other than it's a
pirate game well I didn't really know
what you do inside leaves until I played
it it has a very clear premise you're a
pirate yeah you have a crew what does
that actually mean yeah yeah so what
that actually means
Lucy is you pick up quests you go on
voyages you get plunder and loot or you
kill a skull captain and then you take
your skull back to one of three factions
and then you get rewards for it and then
you go
do that again and on your voyages you
might bump into random enemies in the
world or you might bump into other human
crews there on their own ships and
that's sort of it really it sounds very
basic when I explain it like that but
there's a lot of intricacies to it that
that when you're playing it reveal
themselves so on each ship you you each
have your own role so you can go up in
the crow's nest and you can be the
lookout on your ship or you can be the
one driving the ship or you can be the
one on the cannons Manning the clements
making sure that there's no other enemy
ships coming to fight you and steal all
of your loop because that's the other
thing as well when when you go off on
quests and you bring loot back you have
to protect it like you don't get the
reward straightaway you only get the
rewards when you get back to the outpost
and you give that loot to the captain of
the faction that you've taken that quest
from you might have to fix leaks in the
hull of the ship if you've been attacked
so there's a lot of things to do on your
voyage and each of those sound quite
basic I guess but they're they are very
fun in practice and the fun at least in
my experience of playing it for two
hours with a bunch of other journalists
at rare was the fun came from pretending
to be pirates and chatting to your
friends and having each of those roles
and working together as a team yeah so
when you get me the footage and I was
looking through it to cut this video you
gave me helpfully thank you very much
for this you gave me timestamps of when
you're doing stuff because I think the
video files like an hour and a half long
but they were very long you know like
5-10 minutes where you weren't actually
really doing anything you just sort of
waging from one island to the other and
just looking at that footage I can see
that that doesn't look interesting but I
know having played the game they
actually is because you are looking at
the beautiful horizon the sea the you
know you're you can get your instruments
out and have a dance with the people
that you're on a voyage with and it is
kind of a very strange experience
because it is immersive to a point where
it's just enjoyable yeah walking around
you are a pirate its pleasant yeah like
which is weird because I imagine being a
pirate was very dangerous and on scurvy
yeah exactly there's no scurvy in this
thing
good at least as far as I know but yeah
it's very relaxing and then it does
obviously get exciting when you bump
into other crews or whatever and the
other thing is well I should say I
didn't get a chance to play by myself so
there is a smaller ship nice so there is
a smaller ship that you can pilot is
that the right word your pilot steer
yeah whatever that word is that's a good
show yeah so there is a small ship that
you can take control of which I didn't
get to try so if you don't want to
because when the game releases in the
real world if you don't wanna play with
your mates or if your mates haven't got
the game or if you haven't got any mate
or if you haven't got any mates although
obviously I've got loads of friends Lucy
please don't you can just match make
with random errs but if you don't want
to do that then you can just go out by
yourself but this is where I think that
I think it might be a crucial issue for
sea of Thieves
so if the game comes out and the
community isn't very good or if you just
really don't like playing with other
people then I feel like I feel like it
could fall flat on its face because
unfortunately there's nothing really at
the moment to stop people who are
playing by themselves from getting taken
advantage of by bigger crews because
it's mean well so when you for example
when you when you get into a fight with
another crew there is manic like you
have so much to do all of a sudden you
have to like man the cannons you have to
drop the anchor you have to steer you
have to that's the other things well you
have to you have to steer the sails as
well so because it's the wind so there's
like so many things to do and if you've
also got a leak in in the bottom hull as
well then you've got to go down and fix
that so you still have to do all that
even though you're not exactly that to
me yeah I can totally see we're saying
that feels like it's not gonna work yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be tough if
you're out there by yourself and the
other thing as well there's nothing
really at the moment to stop enemy crews
like I know Nick USCF theives expert
captain Nick captain Nick he was playing
the beast and he said he ran in a few
occasions where he was heading back to a
night post after completing quest and
you get back to the outpost and there
would be a team of four or two teams of
four just camping there waiting for him
to get back so that they could steal his
loot and get the rewards for it so
there's nothing in place
no we're implementing some things to
kinda try and prevent griefing but it
was mostly within team griefing yeah
exactly lock someone in the break yeah
exactly that's the other things I've
seen stories of people who have joined a
match mate randomly and into other teams
like a team of three has had one random
are in and they've just voted to put
them in the brig and then you sort of
stuck there for 20 minutes and the only
thing you can do is quit the game and
come back in which you get much mate
exactly and it seems an inelegant
solution and with the outpost thing I
did ask them about this and they said
their defense was well we're always
adjusting the size of the world and we
specifically put the outpost in
particular places so that you should not
all of the outposts in the world can be
camped on right and if you see someone
in distance then you can just go to
another at post but if you're by
yourself you might not have the ability
to be in the crow's nest if you're also
steering so you might not have that
visibility it's gonna be tricky yeah I
mean so what I was playing I remember
steering the ship and you kind of
actually can't see what you're looking
at you can't see stuff on the horizon
yeah especially with the sails yeah so I
imagine doing that as a single player
would be taxing so I am very interested
to see how the community will respond to
that and it's tricky as well because
that is where the fun of playing as a
crew comes from because like that was a
very deliberate choice because if you're
the one steering you can't see most of
the time because the cells are in the
way and you can't navigate as well
because the map is actually below you in
it on another level of the ship yes
so that inherently creates teamwork
because you have to communicate with
your team and they have to tell you
which way to go and that is where a lot
of fun comes from but if you're by
yourself that's also very difficult
so I think it's gonna be tricky and the
other the other issue that I think the
game might have as well is or at least a
concern that a lot of people in the
community have at the moment is whether
or not is going to have enough content
yes so it did the beta got data mine
didn't it recently it did and people
yeah these concerns was definitely
raised what did you think about the
content that you because were you seeing
I seem it was a final code but it must
have been rare it wasn't ten yeah it was
there sort of like private test server
basically and so we had the full map
available to us how things get I mean
that's a ridiculous we tried asking them
that and they were very coy they sort of
they they refused to put an exact like
square kilometre edge on it they refused
to put an amount of ships on it all they
said was we want you to be bumping into
another ship every 15 to 30 minutes and
they said they're constantly adjusting a
map to fit that so basically they happen
[Music]
with regards to content
I really enjoyed what was there and
definitely they were talking about the
progression system they were talking
about how they're gonna add more quests
and potentially more factions
except the moment there's there's three
main ones as the gold holders which will
task you again
treasure there's the all of souls which
will task you with hunting enemy
captains and bringing their skull back
and there's the merchants alliance which
are a bit more passive and they're sort
of more centered around you're going to
get chickens and pigs and rare animals
in the world and so they what is being a
member of that each guild sort of
grantee so you don't you don't become a
member you just take a quest off of them
and then you vote on which quest you
want to do as a crew right and then when
you bring what they want the bounty back
to them you get rewards like XP and gold
that you can then spend on cosmetic
items basically and there's no micro
transactions they confirm that but I'm
struggling to see whether there's going
to be any depth particularly in the
combat where all of the weapons
essentially behave the same like you can
get a different colored gun right but
it's still the same gun if that makes
sense
yeah there's no
you know like RPG tree kind of thing it
all kind of boils down to you get XP you
level up you get gold which you can use
to buy cosmetic items like you you can
get new cutlasses and a new compass and
but these are all cosmetic changes
usually cosmetics they don't provide any
additional bonuses absolutely none they
were very adamant that they didn't want
to unbalance it for new players and and
I think that's admirable but at the same
time I think that does create some
issues like if I'm 200 hours in and I'm
still using the same musket that I was
using I suppose really like that musket
I mean sure but maybe I want the new
musket by that point and and so that
that is a concern but yeah I think it's
admirable that that they've made it so
that new players even if you're getting
it this time next year you'll still be
able to go in there and you'll have the
exact same equipment and and even really
like a lot of people have been playing
it as an FPS and I don't think it it
really is one like it doesn't the combat
is fairly simplistic so it's not like
something like Call of Duty or
battlefield or Rhema succeed or
overwatch
you're not gonna if you're 300 hours in
you're probably not going to be that
much better at it right the the the
progression in that sense will come from
your knowledge of the map okay they
haven't said whether or not they plan to
add more maps or expand the current one
but they said like is a very deliberate
choice that the map will stay pretty
much the same and that when you're 300
hours in you'll know that map a lot
better and so when you get quest that
that requires you go to a specific
Island you'll know where that is
immediately and you might have an
advantage over newer players in that
sense but is that I mean part of me is
like I admire them for not wanting to
unbalance things everything but is
cosmetic purchasable items enough to
keep people coming back well I think I
think it depends on what else they add
on the new quests and new factions and
like you know someone who buys skins for
me is yeah but then you know they do
that in a in a way where it's like
themed and stuff so I am I mean who
knows maybe rare will do that would see
if thieves maybe you'll get Halloween
see if these costumes you know and they
you'll get that would be cool and I hope
they're I hope they're you know looking
into doing that kind of thing but you
know it's hard to say at this stage
whether or not it's gonna be enough
there aren't any microtransactions so
it's not it's not their way of just
trying to get money out of people and
it's not pay to win so that's admirable
but yeah I think it's hard to say at
this stage and the same with the quest
as well like at least in the limited
amount that I played the quests all seem
pretty similar you go off you get a
thing you come back you go off you get a
thing you come back and there's
obviously there's gonna be more quests
and they're gonna get more complex so I
don't want to definitively say there's
no death but at the moment it looks as
if it it's a little light on content
like the comparison that I specifically
when they were talking about all the
live content they're gonna add a sensor
there's going to be new like public
events and stuff like one example they
gave was you'll get event in-game where
there will be a load of black clouds
will sort of come over this island in
the distance just sort of randomly and
that's sort of their version of a public
event and that will attract a load of
ships to that island because that
essentially means there's treasure to be
there's like a big treasure to be found
with on this island what a battle royale
tip to get it exactly yes that's cool
and I mean I think the question of depth
is also it kind of it depends how much
you as the player and you and as a crew
put into it because those that it feels
to me like see if these is gonna be one
of those games where you create your own
stories definitely and the world the
game itself is sort of just a backdrop
feels like see if these is gonna be one
of those games where you can just settle
into it it's not always gonna be high
octane have a vibe of how the action
action action action action it gives you
these moments to sort of just relax and
chill out with your friends in a non
onna not in an overwhelming kind of
environment yeah but then you know it
leads up to you kind of all get together
and when everyone's ready then you can
take on these
Quest's if you choose to and then just
kind of mess about definitely it's a
hangout game really and that's great and
I think it will be at least I think the
groundwork is there for it to be very
successful as that but when they're
talking about public events and how
they're gonna add new live content and
they spoke a little bit about their
endgame as well which is where you
become a pirate Legend and you get
access to sort of exclusive quests
and I think that's really exciting but
the comparison I sort of find myself
making my head when I was playing it was
this is a bit sort of like destiny but
with pirates destiny the new Dark Soul
and if you compare it to destiny
yeah there's a lot less in there like
destiny has the campaign and then
there's the crucible and then strikes
and then there's raids and sea of
thieves doesn't really have all of that
it just sort of has the hanging out bit
of it but it seems like there is the the
possibility that that could happen and
the game can evolve definitely and I
think they made a comeback they didn't
commit to this but they said they want
to make it a 10-year project again a bit
like destiny exactly and and definitely
they seem really really passionate about
it and and I genuinely believe that they
will add new content and it and I think
that content will be really cool like
they tease the Kraken as well which is
gonna be a really cool thing but yeah
I'm I'm a little worried about its depth
at the moment I can see myself if if I
and three mates get this I can see us
having a great time but then is that new
content good have enough the only way
we'll know is actually playing after
release so I know we're sort of
speculating at this point so I know and
I suppose as well you don't want they
don't want to reveal all the cards
before definitely yeah yes
it's kind of unfair to sort of priam to
be judge it but it's certainly right to
raise concerns yeah it shouldn't you
know based on the fact that we both
spend quite a lot of time in the game by
now actually certainly more than most
games that we go to play pre-release
yeah they've sort of had were that
they're beaters and alphas have been
going on since August last year so so
they've they've it's been a long lead-up
to this game coming out and obviously
today as well
so in conclusion really and I'm really
excited to try it when it's out in the
wild and when I can play it with friends
I have concerns about its longevity and
and about what it's like if you're
playing by yourself but definitely the
the groundwork is there for it to be a
really really cool hopefully expansive
multiplayer adventure well alright those
are our impressions on the recent hands
on of seve thieves Oscar thank you very
much for joining me thank you very much
make sure to subscribe me hearties or
walk the planet these make sure to check
back here to go spot I will never do
that voice okay